damas Makar Chester undelete simmerman
was a hip-hop fan back in around the
year 2000 any rap singer worth his salt
had to have a Cadillac Escalade and
that's what Andrei is testing today an
automatic stepladder makes it easy to
get in the modern ignition button seems
an odd contrast to the old-fashioned
shift lever on the steering column from
the outside there's no mistaking the
impression the escalate intense get out
my way I'm important the brutally
angular appearance almost demands
attention and is the perfect choice for
a rap artist looking to turn adds Andrei
says the 6.2 liter v8 engine can really
get the Escalade moving but most people
prefer to take this Colossus out for a
more leisurely cruise the suspension
provides plenty of comfort despite the
cars huge wheels with Andre notes that
the shock absorbers on the rear axle
don't match those on the front axle the
rear is a bit bumpy another problem is
the brakes which are a bit weak for the
size of the wheels and the overall
weight of the vehicle you really have to
trump on them seems you wanted demonism
yet - almost - should I enlargement the
Escalade ways all of 2.7 tonnes that
weight plus the huge engine means the
Escalade won't win any prizes for fuel
efficiency but a cylinder deactivation
system does bring an average fuel
consumption down to twelve point six
liters per 100 kilometers our test car
has a six-figure price tag
the Escalades exterior is rather
bombastic the LEDs in the headlamps are
mounted in crystal lenses this shorter
model is 5 meters 18 long and more than
2 metres wide an insight in the 2000
says Andre people customise their SUVs
with huge wheel rims today big 22 inch
rims are standard on the Escalade it's
fine sponsors to left and Escalade Andre
recalls how wrappers installed huge hype
i sis tubes and lots of monitors in
their cars a monitor in the rearview
mirror is now standard in the Cadillac
but a self-respecting rapper would now
ask where he can plug in his game
consoles
don't forget the monitors are installed
in the backs of the front seats so
passengers can watch films the interior
has some features you don't immediately
see for example the sound system has
active noise cancellation to minimize
road noise and the Escalades controls
use touch sensitive surfaces instead of
buttons
memens on topic system driving the
Cadillac Escalade Andrei understands why
50 cent thought mike tyson's mansion
where else would there be enough room to
park this fortress on wheels
woman DS assistant all fitted on parking
Khan of course you can find a parking
spot for the Escalade even in Germany if
you have enough time and patience once
you find a space large enough parking
sensors a rear-view camera and a
360-degree camera help you maneuver into
the slot and if that's too much trouble
you can have the car parallel park
itself automatically
[Music]
KTX Cadillacs will remain an exotic site
on german roads for the near future says
Andre the company sells only a few
thousand cars a year in all of Europe
but the Escalade is an important car of
the car makers strategy to expand sales
in Europe Andre says he knows of no
other SUV the Swagger's as much or any
better car to enjoy rap music not just
because of the image but also the Bose
sound system dunk image imposes sound
and lager Basara pro and con
but the Escalade is more for successful
music producers than young rap fans even
the basic model cost 99 thousand euros
in germany a price that guarantees
exclusivity
[Music]